losing an arm in real life is one of the
worst things to happen to someone but in
movies TV and video games
they don't always carry the same
gravitas we've watched Luke Skywalker
thaw that guy from 127 hours an even
group lose an arm or two I'm probably
only one of those at stake with you and
giving you nightmares for three years
now when characters in video games lose
an arm they tend to be in epic battles
shows of superhuman determination or a
quick way to save a few minutes of
effort this is six ways to lose an arm
in video games this will probably make
you feel a little squeamish and all yes
expect spoilers for the following black
ops 3 may not be the most liked Call of
Duty game but it did offer a rather
compelling if slightly ridiculous story
one scene in particular comes to mind
you are trying to open a locked door
which requires two handguns from very
different people and typically you can
only find one of them but don't worry
because your comrade has a plan can't be
serious we're out of time
simply cut off her other hand and scan
that okay while uh back on your journey
The Walking Dead video game is full of
gory moments none more so than the scene
where Lee has been bitten by a walker
and must remove his arm before he
becomes one of them if you decide to
bring along a character one will help
you out worse still if you decided not
to bring any other characters with you
your only option is to cut off your own
arm let's lighten atone for a moment the
Deadpool video game is exactly what
you'd expect from the Merc with a mouth
and as he's unkillable even afar from a
thousand feet isn't made to worry you
sadly for our friend weird
he still has to piece himself back
together but could not find his arm look
not further than his canine companion it
come come lick my balls much better go
boy Oh she'll go jogging a quick shout
out to our Xbox brothers and sisters who
play Gears of War one way to kill an
opponent in that game is to rip off
their own arm and beat them to death
fantastic and now time for another
Mortal Kombat reference metal limbed
American Jack's has a thing for arms
after he lost his two Omak many moons
ago since replacing his arms with super
bionic limbs he now torches his enemies
with his own fate his yaks ripping off
all the arms of all the enemies in
mortal combat Ted
we've reached the top of the list but
before I reveal it I wanted to give a
mention to two games which forced us to
lose a finger rather than a hand or a
whole arm these two are probably the
worst experiences on the list but are
definitely worth crossing you out right
now randomly and until dawn there's a
hand waving at you but don't get too
close because now you've got yourself
trapped and you must release yourself
before the freaky alien catches up with
you and most probably kills you
option one is to slowly open the bear
trap and potentially keep all your
digits but option two is a little bit
more graphic
there's no doubt that until dawn was
heavily inspired by heavy rain and in
one of the scenes in that game our hero
is searching for a way to find his son
if he wants a certain clue from this
encounter he must remove his pinkie
finger using a meat cleaver a saw and
axe maybe some pliers or even a pair of
scissors what a dad will do for his kids
so now it's time to reveal our top pick
in this category and it's from another
Call of Duty game
advanced warfare if you dream about
watching Kevin Spacey die then this is
the choice for you okay so it's not the
real Kevin Spacey so for legal reasons
we must remind you not to kill Kevin
Spacey in this scene we are finally
caught up with the game's antagonist who
is dangling over certain death he
refuses to let go and threatens to take
you and your team down with him so what
does our hero do
you were to pull me up or this whole
building goes down and we go down with
it
yeah II cook softly cybernetic arm and
where's goodbye with his phantom limb
I could watch Kevin Spacey fall to his
death endlessly just one more time oh ma
yeah so that's our list of six ways to
lose an arm in video games have we
missed any others please sound off below
please help us reach more people by
liking and subscribing and maybe even
sharing this video for more videos like
this one come and visit us anytime I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade and I'm
off to watch Kevin Spacey films see you
next time